I'm challenging someone who I think you may know
Someone that I know can almost cook anything on the planet someone who really knows these beef Wellington's all of you, please welcome the amazing
Me!
That's right today. I'll show you how to make the most amazing shrimp scampi in literary ten minutes
Let's have 10 minutes on the clock. You guys ready? Let's go
Now the first thing you need, of course you get that water boiling, 90% of this battle is all about the prep
Okay, so shrimp scampi. I'm gonna start off with a shallot
I'll chop that don't go fine dice. Just slice it. Okay, again a lot quicker. So slice it in half
Okay, if you slice it too thin it's gonna burn so just slice
the nice slices
Shallots beautifully done.
I like the shallots over the onion the shallots make it a little bit sweeter
and more importantly it's a lot easier to digest
Slice the onions don't get too fancy. Okay
from there
little splash of olive oil now
Water's boiling, splash of oil in, splash the oil in. I actually like this with a little bit of heat in there
Okay, so I got some chili flakes, I'm going to finish it with some fresh basil
Once the oil is up to temp shallots in, now
caramelize those shallots
Lightly season them okay? A bit of salt and pepper
I don't worry if they don't break down easily
by the time they're cooked they'll start breaking down
now
from there
A little drizzle of olive oil, okay,? Get that turning in, break down the shallots
now when you're cooking and
You're up against it time wise, trust me start using techniques rather than chopping everything
So I've got this microplane that we use obviously - to grate parmesan, lemon
take a nice clove of garlic. Okay, and literally grate that
Over those shallots the garlic disintegrates so much quicker. Okay, you get right down to the wire and look
underneath there
It's beautiful. It's sort of almost purees the garlic for you. And then from there take a little knife
Take that all in there. So
tap it
And literally get that really nice
Caramelization on that garlic and those wonderful shallots now once you've browned off the shallots
Okay from there
Literally turn up the heat, get that really nice and hot now start off too hot and you'll burn those shallots
Okay
Check in on the time
Now a little touch of chili flake. Okay chili flakes in there
Lightly sprinkle, those chili flakes. You can always add more heat but you can't take it away. So be smart with that
and then
Get your tomatoes, I want a little bit of acidity in this dish. And again, I'm going to just cut these tomatoes in half
Okay, and what's that gonna do? It's gonna blister in the pan but more importantly it's gonna give it that really nice sweetness
Three or four little cherry tomatoes, okay? That's where the acidity comes in, open them up
And you'll hear them sort of almost start to blister and roast. Now, as the 'matoes start to break down
Okay, my shallots are caramelizing, the garlic has disintegrated beautifully
Break those down and then from there, I'm going to deglaze the pan
Basically, I'm gonna sort of clean the pan out with a little tablespoon of white wine
White wine goes in
Turn up the gas
Break that down. Now look what's happening, the tomatoes are disintegrating, the shallots
Are super caramelized, that garlic's disappeared, chili flakes giving it the heat
And then from there a tablespoon of stock: vegetable stock, chicken stock
Or even fish stock in don't flood it, okay
Try to create a really nice sauce. You don't start cooking your pasta until that is absolutely ready. Okay
Now once that's on and it starts to sort of reduce down
Literally back on
How long we got? Um... 7 minutes
Oh my lord, I'll go for a run
Get your pan on
Keep that boil rolling for your pasta. Get your pan on nicely. Now. Look at that
It's reduced down to a syrup. This is where it goes even more fragrant. Take your basil
Get your largest leaf, your small leaves on the outside
Okay
and from there
The nice thing about that, get your large leaf
Okay, get the small leaves, tuck them inside the large leaf and roll it like a beautiful big cigar
Okay? Hold it nice and tight
let the knife do the work and
Literally chiffonade that basil, now, here's where it goes up a notch, okay?
That's beautiful caramelizing down there. Okay? Nice!
Basil goes on
So we're halfway, just under five minutes to go. Capers: a little bit of the acid and saltiness there
But look, that's the sauce. That's
Where the magic is right there, so we're halfway
Now take your shrimp. Okay?
lightly season the shrimp
salt and pepper
seasoned nicely
salt
pepper
Okay, get them really nicely seasoned
They only take literally 90 seconds to cook, 90 seconds for the pasta, 90 seconds for the shrimp. Okay.
My pan is nice and hot
Teaspoon of olive oil in there, in with the pasta and look I want color on those shrimp, they go in
Beautiful
Shrimp are in
Don't overseer these shrimp. Okay? They turn dry
So the nice thing now is that shrimp are on, sauce is ready. Take your capellini
in
to your water
okay, in
That starts to boil up, take it, twist it round
and
it literally cooks in 90 seconds, turn up the gas, turn that around and you'll see that coming together, beautifully
Time please how long left? Ahh... Just under 4 minutes.
Once that shrimp are colored, look, take them off the gas, turn them around
Okay, look at the color on there. Beautiful, really beautiful. Pasta's boiling
Watch olive oil on top, beautifully done. Take that zest of lemon. And I want to literally
Zest my
lemon over there
Look at that. We're just under three minutes to go
Pasta's cooking nicely. I using a capellini, okay? So it's super thin and really quick to cook
I haven't overfilled the pan with water. Sometimes you put too much water in the pan. You lose the capellini. So keep the water to a minimum
shrimp
Beautifully rested I'm going to put them in to my sauce. There, just like that
Bring that back up to temp
Now look
The less water you've got in that pasta
The quicker it cooks, okay?
And from there, take that out, check
Still nice and firm. So literally another 30 seconds in there
Sometimes when you fill up a pan with water you put your capellini in and you lose it all so I like the small pan
Half full of water and so the pasta cooks quicker, but you don't lose anything
Shrimp resting back inside the shallots and the blistered tomatoes and look
So just under two minutes to go, capellini literally is... you go through it with your fingers
It's cooked colander in
back over
out
Draining under the pan. I like putting the capellini back into the pan and then literally mixing that around
Glazing it with oil. 60 seconds to go
now
shrimp, capellini
I'm gonna mix that shrimp with my capellini
Beautifully done
In, not too much pasta
Remember the hero is the shrimp and then look I'm mixing this all up now. Beautifully done, I'm gonna twist that round
I'm going to sit the pasta and beautifully in the center of the plate and then garnish that in my shrimp
Now, I want all those shallots
and all that beautiful sauce
And look, how do I finish that?
for dinner
Honestly
Parmesan
over the top
Right at the last minute and then finally, just a nice
pinch
Of zest and then very quickly
The lemon and fresh lemon and there you have the most amazing
shrimp capellini done in 10 minutes
Do not forget to subscribe to my amazing Youtube channel and good luck! Can't wait to see what you can do in 10!